and I didn't come back to the second
stage search fund idea but one of the
things we've we've done quite a bit of
in in the recent years is we've had very
targeted search fund so entrepreneurs
who have come out of some of our core
industries we do a lot of investing and
small-market cable television other
small market media we've looked at a lot
of broadcast TV and small market radio
and some other niche media businesses so
one of the strategies that we've had is
to find some of the best operators in
those markets people who want to stay in
but they don't want to keep running you
know twenty thousand subscriber systems
for you know one of the large MSOs
they'd rather get out buy something
they've always wanted to you know be an
owner operator so in my comment
certainly relates more to second stage
search fund entrepreneurs but i think
also you know if if there are people who
have you know have some extensive
experience in an industry and they still
want to be in that industry and it's one
that you know there are maybe there is
some fragmentation of the industry and
there is an opportunity to buy and and
operate i I wouldn't you know if that's
that's on your radar and you're
passionate about it that's great
you know from our point of view that's a
terrific thing I think you can also be
passionate about the process of building
a great company some people know the
industry they want to be in and they're
passionate about that industry but I
also think you can say I'm passionate
about building a great company and I'm
going to find the right industry I don't
know what it is right now these are some
of the ones that I've analyzed and
appeal to me for the following reasons
but I'm not coming to you as an investor
and representing that I'm going to end
up in one of these industries but I am
going to try to build a great company
and I'd love to have you be an investor
I think that's a credible thing to say
as well
I'm living in that scary time right now
I guess you know you learn just along
the way I found and you lean heavily on
the board and the other investors who
have the time and inclination to be
active with you and I think at the end
of the day it's not rocket science I
mean structuring fancy warrants and
burnouts is a little more complex but
let's get down to the basics of you know
cash at clothes similar note turnout
those are the kind of key knobs that you
use and then it's negotiating with the
seller I had zero private equity
experience or deal experience and I
don't think Josh right feels handicapped
by that at this stage I would add to
that hire a very good lawyer just try to
get someone who is an experienced deal
lawyer dealmaker lawyer they can guide
you through that process and you know
that is it's gonna cost you money but
certainly a attentive valuable resource
I think in terms of putting together
turn like figure out like what do you go
pay and how are you gonna put together
an offer and was it what does the letter
of intent know I think I had a couple of
friends who had five companies and so I
got their letters that they sent to the
sellers and I got their letters of
intent term sheets and just collected a
bunch of them tried to make up my own
from there and I think yeah having a
good lawyer
I guess that's after a deal has been
accepted and I have a lawyer take a look
at my letter of intent but I think I
went off of other people's templates
we we use them but we don't use them
exclusively I think once you get to know
a group of business brokers they also
get to know what you're looking for what
industries you're interested in what
size range you're interested in at the
end of the day of business burger can
save you a lot of time because they'll
at least bring you a business that's
actually for sale as opposed to one
that's just trying to get a free
valuation service right now I I didn't
find brokers to be helpful when I was
doing my search fund and I just
preferred the approach of targeting an
industry and getting to know that
industry and and I think even once in
the industry there are some brokers in
our industry I felt I didn't really need
them because it's such a small industry
that I could I could source deals on my
own and and some brokers that that
broker's fee is a chunk of business that
can make the difference between what
they're able to close a deal or not I
had coffee the other day with a man
named Chris Flanagan he actually was the
author of the search fund study that
some of you have seen he's been looking
for a company based in Dallas he's based
in Dallas looking for a company he's
been out looking just about a year and I
said Chris what what is the single thing
you would do differently in the past
year if you had it to do over and he
said I would not search
opportunistically I would search only by
industry he said I've wasted a
tremendous amount of time trying to
analyze the companies that friends or
bankers or brokers brought in and it
took me a long time to realize that I
can't just analyze the company I've got
to analyze the industry on the
competitive position and it's a very
inefficient way to search that way so
that's a little bit counterintuitive in
the sense that you think well I want to
buy a company why don't I tell my
friends I want to buy sort of this kind
of
phanie with these parameters and some of
the things that have been mentioned but
not be specific about the industry and I
think the answer is that it's very hard
to and inefficient to analyze the flow
of companies that comes in and time goes
by your scarcest resources your time
I would actually think the data is
different than that it's interesting
because I think you would you would
think that second stage search funders
have a better track record than first
stagers but at least our look at the
data suggests that first time search
funds are still a very good investment
for somebody to make and I think part of
that might be one of the hypotheses that
we have is actually on the second stage
group that there's a sense that I'm more
experienced and I can handle more more
complexity more you know a bigger
company and they have tended to get
themselves into trouble sometimes on
that second go-round so at least our
look at the data is that first time
search funds overall have been very
successful I think actually the GSB
study would support that as well but the
key if you look at what's been
successful and what hasn't is the
quality of the business and it's things
like like one of the things we think is
one of the insights into selecting the
businesses is the complexity of a
company of the industry for example if
if the CEO and his direct reports are
spending all of their time thinking you
know okay here it is November 18th how
am I going to make the November numbers
you know what do we got to do how are we
going to scrambler on get that done
versus if they have a business that is
you know has characteristics such that
the operation of the company is is less
complex it's it's got some other
characteristics very strong recurring
revenue high margins etc it allows the
team to step back and be more strategic
and be thinking about how to add value
in a much more strategic way
III think that that that what you do and
dress will search for as you raise
enough money to last for two to three
year period and try to do a budget of
what you think your operating expenses
are going to be so the size of the the
initial search one really shouldn't
matter as to the you know what what deal
size you end up you end up doing you
certainly want to give some indication
to your investors as to how big a deal
you want to do because you want to let
them know that you might be calling upon
them for an X amount per per investment
but I would I would tell you not to
limit yourself to the amount of capital
do we raise shouldn't be the limit to
what you do if you find a deal that
that's bigger than what you originally
thought you would do and it requires
more capital well you know take it to
your mistress and see if you can get it
done
in terms of the amount of money it can
range anywhere from 15,000 to 35,000 and
investor typically you know I it's it's
you know it's maybe a dozen or so
investors would be the right amount you
need more than that for a first-time
search fund you may be herding cats even
with a dozen you may be herding cats
when it comes time to close the deal
people did you have to see to get 12
investors we made in person or over the
phone pitches to probably around 75
people and I'd guess probably
middle-of-the-road you basically want to
only accept a search fund investment
from someone that you're quite confident
and follow-on with you know 10 to 15 X
to their initial investment if you bring
them a deal so whatever that means so
personal net worth of 5 to 10 million
dollars it's hard to say because you
can't just walk in and ask someone what
their personal net worth is so there's
really no easy way to determine whether
just you kind of just get a general
sense of how long the person has been in
their career you know if they've got
family money it's you wind up sometimes
accidentally pitching people who don't
have money and they kind of tell you
people have pitch you know their family
dentists and stuff ladies it's you can
get get right down there this
occasionally I know other search ones
they have taken investment money from
friends just like associates who clearly
won't be able to follow on with a full
complement of falun capital but they
feel it's nice it's a nice incentive for
them to really perform because they
don't to let their friends down is also
a nice signal to other investors that
you have one or two friends or family in
that you know you're going to do more
than lose investors money you lose
personal money in a way if I may add I
think from we took a similar approach to
the way that we assembled the board we
thought very strategically who we wanted
and why and I think are most effective
closings potential investors were those
that we could last a very we want you to
be in
best friend here's why because you Brand
X Y and C to the table and that's
exactly what we're looking for so try to
in if possible make a list of people
that you will want to try to tailor it
to very specific reasons what you want
them in your group one way that a
raising a search fund often goes
although they're variants is that you
see 60 to 80 people you call a lot more
than that because some just blow you off
on the phone but you have meetings with
60 or 80 people and you get a few early
adopters who say yes you get a lot of
people who say no and then you get some
people to say well this is all new to me
I don't know keep me posted
maybe later not now and when you raise
let's say you're trying to raise twelve
units when you've raised seven units you
then can go back to that last group of
people and say the train is leaving the
station would you like to be a board and
psychologically that's a very different
proposition from saying we're thinking
about this train would you have any
interest in a train ride
I think the biggest blow that you can
have is start working on a deal and you
you actually get into a an acquisition
process you sign a letter of intent
you're all happy you think you're gonna
get it through you start spending money
and account that's doing accounting due
diligence you start spending money legal
due diligence and all the senator deal
closed at your face you're out forty
fifty thousand dollars in fees what do
you do I mean that that I think is the
one thing that you have to be really
careful as to when you start spending
actual money in each deal and try to
meet it mitigate all the risks
associated with closing that deal before
you actually open the faucet and okay
start drafting documents start doing due
diligence on the accounting side that
can you know I've know some people where
they that has happened and it actually
happened to us at one point in time and
fortunately we had negotiated a breakup
fee and luckily we were able to collect
it but I think that's that's in our in
our in our view that was the biggest
potential unexpected that you can have
let me comment to this because I think
after raising a few hundred thousand
dollars basically selling someone an
option to invest in you you get pretty
bold and so I went to lawyers and
accountants and I said and I interviewed
a bunch of them and basically the deal
was I'm trying to put together an
acquisition and I'd like you to work for
me
pro bono and I'll pay you when the deal
gets done and if the first deal doesn't
happen I'm not gonna be able to pay you
but we're gonna get a deal done and
surprisingly enough there there were
some lawyers who were willing to do it I
mean I think I've met with two two
lawyers who are willing to do it and
then I think Cooper's and Libran an
accounting firm also was willing to do
it so they've been I was gonna do a lot
of things later
so you can be pretty resourceful in ways
to conserve cash and I remember I paid
rent for I think it was three hundred
and eighteen dollars a month you know I
still remember that that was a big check
personal money how about three years of
foregone income that's I mean I think
most in most cases you don't actually
put your own money but what you do is
that during the search front period you
take a very reduced salary when you
would be making the open market so if
you figured you'd be making seventy five
hundred thousand dollars at our business
school you're paying yourself fifty
during the whole process then in effect
you're contributing the difference of
that money throughout the search process
I think you yeah I don't think you need
to put your own money in I did but I
don't think it really I thought it was
gonna make a difference when I was
selling my search I don't think
investors really care if we have a
couple cents to rub together we may put
it in the deal
I'm from the era of $50,000 a year
compensation I don't know what it is
these days during the search for 40
post-deal current I guess post deal
compensation we're at it I think about a
hundred thousand you know so this is
1997 and kind of I would say below
market until maybe two two years ago and
then there's the equity component which
obviously you're you're you're sweating
for so but you know I think it probably
depends on the size company you buy and
whether you have a partner or not there
are lots of factors that impact your
your current compensation implicit in
John's comment is is a carried interest
that the search funder or search funders
get some of it is at the closing some of
it may be vest may vest over time and
some of it may be performance-based so
that they're really not expected to put
money in as has been said and they
expect to end up with fifteen to thirty
percent of the deal it varies according
to the situation but the the real on the
come is is the is the equity that's
really why you're doing this financially
that there are other reasons to do it
but the main reason to do it financially
is for the equity interest and my
impression and John Fowler maybe you can
correct me if I'm wrong is that search
funders lately have been taking 70 80
thousand dollars salary kind of during
the search fund is that I yeah round 70
although you know I've heard of more
heard of less I've also heard is that no
investors that were pushed back to say
take less salary if you ask for it and
you can justify it they'll get what you
asked for
that's uh it's a challenge because you
have you know you're gonna close on a
multi-million dollar transaction you
don't have the money and you're telling
you do you know or at least you're
saying here my group of investors
they're hot you know I brought them up
to speed on the business they've seen
yeah you can walk them through it
and even having your investors maybe
speak with the seller if the seller is
nervous about it you can always have
them talk to some of the the folks that
you know piece of tonic partners or one
of your other lead investors I think
that helps but again getting to know
that the seller and if they see who is
credible and trustworthy and you stick
by your commitments and you're following
through with every conversation you have
they're not going to have such doubts
a couple of things one relation
relationship building so they're not
going to do that I mean really getting
them to buy into you and to is in a
letter of intent you can have you can
actually put something that's legally
binding in there which we do the letter
of intent is not legally binding except
for one section I think where we say
that they it's a exclusivity clause
where they're not going to shop it to
anybody else within a decent time frame
so that that helps and also when people
sign a letter of intent hopefully
they're not going to you know go to
start looking elsewhere and part of it
is just good faith there's a big psychic
element to in many of these transactions
where you may often be dealing with a
seller who is older and you strike a
bond with them and they are thinking all
the time can I entrust my baby to this
person or these people there's a there
are non financial motivations to at play
and to the extent that you can build
those those bonds which which john is
alluded to but I'm just underlining it
just strengthens your ability to carry
forward the transaction
I think it was you Javed sure Tobias
that I that I share as well that you
don't I think it you're better off
structuring something where there's a
there's a period of time where that
seller is there to help you get over the
hump help you attach the customer
relationships to you or somebody on your
team you want to move that over from
them you want to I think it can be
helpful with the employee group that
they see a little smoother transition
but you want to have a relatively short
period of time at which point it's clear
that they are out and and you are the
only one then home and I think sort of
you know 6 to 12 maybe 15 months is kind
of the right timeframe at least that's
our point of view
I think there are a number of new search
funds cropping up but shockingly somehow
we have not been competing against them
on deals I can't explain it I think it's
just a lot of teals out there even
though doesn't seem like they get done
every other day it's a pretty big pool
we swim in yeah I think it has something
to do with the size range that search
fund entrepreneurs are looking at which
is it's the reason Housatonic is so
active with search funds is there's
overlap there and we just you know 95
you know we count this up every year but
95 percent of the investments we've made
in our history
we're non-competitive which is really
you know a unique statement in the
private equity world but I think you
know it has more to do with the size
that we're all looking in and there's
just a lot of opportunity there and we
also keep in touch with the number of
the other active search ones at least in
the Bay Area and we know generally often
what industries they're looking at so we
don't overlap on industry networking so
we're not I'll be into each other at
trade shows
the most common is is always going to be
a strategic sale sale to a larger
competitor in that marketplace that that
holds for Housatonic in our you know in
our non search fund deals and again I
think it's just it's a function of your
taking a company from sort of twenty
million of enterprise value to you know
maybe fifty maybe you know maybe beyond
but you're in that sort of a realm so
you're not talking about sort of IPO
exits although there are some search
fund deals that I think really are
candidates out there in the marketplace
now but strategic sale is going to be
the most common I think
I can talk about the Geographics crypsis
that's exactly what we did
there's some pros and cons the process
if you're from that geographic region
that might give you a head starting that
you know the people you know many of the
sellers you know many of the companies
you may have relationships in that area
that hopefully will make it easier or at
least so we thought and that's that's
some of the positives that we see some
of the negatives are that when you start
doing your industry analysis and you say
okay I'm gonna pick these five
industries that I really like though I'm
gonna start with the widget industry and
then you say okay the widget industry
scrape and they're only five companies
in the area and you go and talk to all
five of them and not I don't wanna sell
so then you know you got to strike that
one out so those are that's how I would
balance it you know there's there's a
good that you may have a head starting
that you know people and the downside is
that it truly limits the amount of
potential candidates that you can look
at and then the first half of your
question certainly anything with
companies with assets out there have
been easier to get debt financing for
most recently we've certainly found that
I think John's point earlier about
seller financing being a key part of
your structure that you want for other
reasons are becoming even more important
now that really what's happening out
there to bring prices down is we're just
saying look we just can't get debt
financing so we need a lower price plus
you're gonna have to take some of that
debt financing so the seller notes are
actually growing they're becoming more
important it's a fairly hard job Raphael
and his partner did it but it's a fairly
hard job to convince investors that you
can find a company in let's say the Bay
Area I think you really have to have a
broader focus than that and say I'm
willing to go to these five western
states I'm willing to move anywhere at
least for a while you know it's not for
the rest of your life necessarily it
might be for the next three four five
six years and maybe you can morph the
company that you buy in Tulsa to move
the headquarters here a sure
which is one of the great search fund
success stories bought a company in
Houston and moved it to the Bay Area but
I think it's very hard to say we're
gonna buy a company in the Bay Area or
we're gonna buy a company in Chicago or
Boston and that's the only area we're
going to look in investors really want
more chances to win than that
I look at a lot of different businesses
in my industry so I got a pretty good
sense of a quality company from not a
quality company and when you review
financial statements in combination with
a tour of the facility and really
understanding their organizational
structure you get a pretty clear picture
on what a good company is and what it
not so good company is and so we tried
to focus for us it was do they have
quality client base Ric the repeat
recurring type client base do they have
a team of managers and sales people
who've been with the company for a while
and who could perform and do a good job
the quality their assets for us is the
quality of the rental assets are the
white wood chairs white sort of things
you get a general you walk into a place
you get a general vibe of what it's like
is is the the owner someone who
delegates or not is everything flowing
up to the top and where they're making
every single decision you know I don't
think you want to buy a company like
that but if you see that if you walk
into a business you spend an hour to
there you get a real good feel for
whether it's a good business or not and
in combination with the financials I
think it helps you evaluate a business
and seeing a whole bunch of other
businesses in that industry is very
helpful and it's surprising how people
will open up their doors to you
one thing that you learn it's the kind
of thing that they tell you before you
go into it but you really don't learn to
you'll actually out there one of the
toughest thing is to is to ascertain
whether you have a motivated seller or
not or if it's just someone that just
sitting there one day you call and he
says well maybe should I don't know if I
should sell my business or not you know
it sounds like a good idea I think did
you string you along in the end and say
well you know I just wanted to know what
my business was worth so I think it has
to start you have to spend a lot of time
trying to ascertain what it is why this
person wants to set are they for real or
not I mean I don't know I can't answer
with that percentage but every time that
that we got stringed along we went back
and said you know what happened here so
well this person did not really have a
need to sell their you know I think
that's very very important and those
reasons for selling can be secession
health divorce you know number reasons
we've only found two or three sellers
that didn't think they want to sell who
then claimed they wanted to sell but
it's been our ongoing experience that
they actually just wanted to sell for
seven times
EBIT or six times EBIT does so they're
not really realistically looking to sell
what we also look for with all sorts
every sellers the the true motivation
behind selling like these is it
retirement or is that they're getting
out when the getting's good and they
clean something's about to fall off the
cliff you always got a raise an eyebrow
once the 37 year old selling the
business you know to spend more time
with the kids at home because if he's
earning to be million-and-a-half down to
the his pocket every year there's
something something going on so
I think at first if you are married I
think the first thing is you need to do
is make sure that your wife's on board
and I truly mean this because this is
once you embark on doing this it is an
emotional rollercoaster you don't know
exactly where you're gonna be living if
you choose not to like we did do it your
graphic search you don't know what
company you're gonna be running so I
mean it's a very trying time that can be
very stressful on your spouse so then
you need to make sure that she
understands that this is gonna be a
roller coaster ride sometimes you know
you feel you're the king of the world
the seller just called you he definitely
wants you to buy your company wants to
sell the company to you and then three
weeks later you feel like the biggest
month because the guy all the sudden
doesn't want to talk to you anymore and
and then you add to that that you know
this takes some people get luck here or
they work harder at it and get it done
in a year but others take two three
years so that that in terms of balancing
your work life with and personal like
the first thing that I would say is make
sure that that your significant other is
on board the one thing in that is true
which is what I said before you do have
more control or at least perceived
control of your time as to how you
allocate it no one thinks you know you
can do our personal level but you still